if it's been a bit of a longer gap
between a project I am a bit like all
like this is a kind of a comfortable
moment as I kind of try on that kind of
role again yeah I think it's always that
you know if you obsess too much about
thinking you need to be the leader of
this group and like let's go you know
I've got all the ideas and I know
everything then you're not it's going to
be stressful like you say that if you
just focus on the script the story just
that scene also just really lean on the
people you're collaborating with you
know you've hired and them for a reason
when it comes to these other people and
I think the best lesson I learned too is
I often used to think like I need the
answer right now or I need to interpret
like how that take went and quickly now
give my direction like right you know
and need to always have it fully formed
and I think the best thing I learn is
just know and be okay with moments where
I'm like let's just take a couple of
minutes like I'm just gonna think before
I say and not just immediately give a
direction that I'm like actually no
that's not what I meant